Did you know that some races in One Piece
have natural elemental abilities like fire,
water, and electricity?
Or that Buggy the Clown might be related to
a tribe of cannibals?
And I bet you never knew that the Yonko Kaido,
this venomous jailer, and this evil pirate
might actually all be a part of a secret ancient
race that has been hiding for HUNDREDS of
chapters.
So let’s explain every secret, history,
and crazy special abilities for every single
race in One Piece.
Of course starting with the massive men and
women of the giant race, whose culture is
based on Norse mythology.
Now obviously we know that giants are literally
the tallest people in the world.
In fact, THE SMALLEST giant is an absurd twelve
meters tall, which is like stacking about
seven average people on top of each other.
And that is just the smallest one.
Yeah, this race is MASSIVE with some of the
tallest giants reaching heights of over 20
meters tall.
And with incredible size comes insane natural
power and we have even been told that on average
giants are the strongest fighters in the world,
which just makes a lot of sense.
I mean would you want this massive ax or sword
coming down on you?
One thing you may not know though is that
while the giant’s most well known island
is Elbaf, there are actually giants who come
from all over the world.
Which leads us to the most mysterious thing
about the giants is that there appear to be
secret groups among the giants that have even
more special abilities.
For example, these snowy giants that we met
in Punk Hazard are TWICE as tall as normal
giants and are covered with fur.
There are also Giant and Fishmen hybrids,
which don’t even ask me how that happened,
but these people are called Wotans just like
this guy who we met during the Long-Ring Long
Land arc.
Then of course the most powerful giants are
the Ancient Giants, also sometimes called
Demon giants.
And these guys take it to a whole new level.
The only two confirmed members of the Ancient
giants.
The first is Oars, who lived centuries ago
and was called a Continent Puller, and the
second is his descendant, Little Oars Jr.
who helped free Ace during the battle at Marineford.
On top of their extra size and strength, these
two seem like more beast than person with
their horns and sharp fangs, but the next
race in one piece is even more furry.
That’s because the Minks are a tribe of
human-like animals who live on the back of
this massive elephant.
Now what might surprise you is that there
is a very clear split on what the Minks look
like depending on their gender.
For example, the males are basically full
on animals who just walk on two legs, while
the females tend to look more human with some
added animal features like fur and animal
ears.
But despite some of their cute appearances,
this race is extremely powerful for two main
reasons.
First, they are one of ONLY THREE RACES in
the one piece world who can naturally control
an elemental ability.
And we’ll talk about the other two in just
a minute, but the Minks can use Electro, which
adds electricity to their attacks.
Which is stupidly powerful if you ask me.
But their Sulong transformation.
And wow, this is both beautiful AND terrifying
because when a mink looks at a full moon,
their fur turns completely white and they
gain unbelievable boosts in speed, powers,
and endurance.
There is a downside though because if a Mink
doesn't learn how to control the power and
turn back to normal they can literally kill
themselves by going berserk for too long.
And like most non-human races, they have a
pretty dark history, because at one point
they had to flee to the back of this giant
elephant.
Which if you ask me, it was probably to escape
being wiped out by our next race.
That’s because there is no race as destructive
as humans.
Now of course there is a huge variety of humans,
from the pretty average weak human all the
way up to the monstrously powerful ones like
Big Mom who can wipe out an entire tribe of
giants all on her own.
But despite their individual powers, we already
know that humans didn’t always rule the
world.
In fact, some of the other overpowered races
we will talk about in just a few minutes were
once considered gods, but humans were likely
able to conquer the world thanks to their
advanced technology and scientific advancements.
However, you probably didn’t ever realize
that there are many unique groups of humans
scattered around the world.
Of course, there is the Kuja tribe, who are
the warrior women of Amazon Lily who seem
to have a natural ability to use haki.
Plus they somehow only give birth to women.
So no men for this tribe, unless you are Luffy
of course.
There are also tons of humans who have super
strange appearances, such as the chestnut
on top of this guy’s head, the round, squishy
noses of the cannibalistic Kumate tribe who
might actually be relatives of Buggy.
There are also ape humans and the horned humans
like the Emperor Kaido, this mad scientist,
the warden of Impel Down Magellan, and this
member of Blackbeard’s crew.
Because even though their horns all look a
bit different, they could all actually be
the descendants of ancient giants, who also
had these massive horns.
Seriously, I just need to know if these are
just random design choices by the author or
if there actually some giant ancestry tree
that explains all of these interesting features.
Now, while there are so many mysteries surrounding
humans, one of the MOST MISUNDERSTOOD races
are the fishmen and merfolk.
That’s because these are actually TWO.
SEPARATE.
RACES.
And obviously, Oda took inspiration from the
mermaid myths in our world to create his merfolk,
you may not have realized that he basically
reversed this idea to come up with the fishmen.
So merfolk have a fish lower body and human
upper body, while fishmen who have a human
lower body and fish-like features on their
upper bodies.
But even with these differences they can both
live in the sea and can have kids together.
So let’s break down the differences a bit
more.
Because the actual fish-men all have gills
and lungs which means they can live on both
land and sea.
Fishmen are also naturally ten times stronger
than the average human, and on top of that,
they usually have some special characteristics
based on what type of fish they are.
Take Arlong, for example, who is a sawshark
fishman, and one of his special abilities
is that he can regrow his teeth immediately,
kinda like how a shark has many rows of teeth.
Or take this octopus fishman, who can squirt
ink just like an actual octopus.
But most importantly is that the fishmen are
the second major group with the ability to
control an element because with their Fishman
Karate they can manipulate water into bullets,
slashes, spears, and much, much more.
Seriously, this might be the most underused
OP ability in the story…
But moving on.
Now, all of this is separate from merfolk,
which includes mermaids and mermen who are
naturally born with a fish-like tail.
Now, the men will ALWAYS have this tail, but
luckily the women can choose to split their
tail once they turn thirty, so they can walk
around on two legs.
And while they don’t have as many special
abilities as the fish-men, they are officially
the fastest swimmers in the ocean AND they
can communicate with other fish in the sea.
Next we’re gonna get a little weird because
even though they are different races, the
merfolk and fishmen can have kids together,
and this can produce an child that is either
merfolk or fish-men.
However, even that can’t compare in weirdness
to this next race, or I guess races, as we
discuss the long…
uhh, body parts tribes.
And I’m of course talking about the Long-Arm,
Long-Leg, and Snakeneck races.
Which are basically all just like they sound,
and are surprisingly based on ancient Japanese
creatures.
The Long-legs tribe have extra long legs,
like Big Mom’s daughters here.
The Snakenecks have freakishly long necks,
but the long arm tribe take it one step further
because they have an entire extra elbow in
each of their arms, which means they can bend
their arms in unnatural directions.
The most famous of these is the musical pirate
Scratchman Apoo.
But there’s one thing I bet you didn’t
know because while these three groups don’t
play an important role in the story, the Long
Arm and Long Leg tribes have been fighting
a war that goes back all the past to the Void
Century.
Which is just kinda crazy to think that they’ve
been fighting for longer than the World Government
has been in power.
Now we’re not quite done with longish body
parts yet, because next we have Luffy’s
stretchy thing.
Wait, wait, hold on.
That wasn’t supposed to be in here.
Just forget about that and subscribe to the
channel for more one piece content just like
this.
Anyway, there is actually one more strange
group of people with extra long heads.
And while we don’t officially have a name
for them, we’ll just call them the Long
Head People, who have a surprising number
of named characters.
For example, there is this marine Vice-admiral,
this scientist who sent automata to the moon,
this pointy headed pirate, and this ninja
leader.
What you won’t believe though is that the
Sky People are one of the most interesting
groups in the entire story, and are clearly
based on angles.
As we know from the Skypiea arc, there are
three separate groups of Sky People, although
they might have once been all the same.
They are the Skypieans, the Shandorans, and
the Birkans, who all have differently shaped
wings and share a common background.
You see, during Enel’s cover story, we learned
that the winged people once lived on the moon
and that they eventually had to float down
to the planet because of a lack of resources.
The Birkan and Skypiens settled on the clouds
and the Shandorans settled on the island of
Jaya down on the sea.
And while we don’t know a ton more about
their ancient histories, we do know that the
Shandian people were once friends with the
Ancient Kingdom and were even trusted with
a Poneglyph.
Honestly though, all three groups of sky people
don’t have any special abilities.
They can’t even fly with their wings, which
is a major disappointment.
Although they do make good use of the natural
resources located in the sky such as the dials
and seastone.
But speaking of special abilities, the one
race with the most OP ability in the story
is the Three-Eyed tribe, which may have been
inspired by ancient Hindu and Tao beliefs.
Now, just like another extremely important
tribe we will discuss in a moment, we only
know one confirmed member of the three eyed
tribe.
That is of course Big Mom’s daughter, Pudding,
who is a half-blood member of the mysterious
tribe.
Which I guess means there has to be at least
one more out there somewhere, her father or
something.
Unfortunately though, we don’t know about
them except they have the insane ability to
awaken the Voice of All Things.
Which if you don’t remember, this ability
allows anyone to essentially understand the
basics of any spoken or written communication,
like when Luffy could vaguely understand what
was being said by these massive Sea Kings.
And because this is such an important ability,
I certainly believe that Pudding or another
member of her tribe will play a massive role
in the story later on.
Now from one of the most important races,
let’s shift to what is honestly one of my
favorite races in One Piece, the Dwarves,
who are based on real world Scandinavian myths.
And man, these tiny creatures are simply incredible
because despite their size they are actually
EXTREMELY POWERFUL, with an average dwarf
being able to easily destroy an entire building.
Plus with their small size they are experts
at sneaking around and remaining unseen, and
they are incredibly talented at growing natural
things.
However, despite all the positives, the dwarves,
or more specifically the dwarves we met in
Dressrosa have an extremely dark past.
Because just like many other races, they were
forced into slavery for hundreds of years.
Luckily they were freed, but still, if we’ve
learned anything so far, it’s that humans
can be pretty awful.
What you may not know though is that there
may be an entirely separate tribe of dwarves
because back in Big Mom’s library we saw
this tiny creature pinned in a book.
This is a Kinokobito, and while we don’t
know anything else about it, its small size
may mean it is related to the dwarves.
And there is also a pun here in the Japanese
name because Kinoko translates to mushroom
while Bito means human, so the name literally
means Mushroom Human.
Now, prepare yourselves for this next race
because they are probably the most individually
powerful in the entire world.
I am talking about the Lunarian tribe, who
we were first introduced to during the final
battle in Wano.
And this tribe has a lot of symbolism relating
to the moon.
I mean their name literally mean Moon people,
but they are also associated with highest
ranking Christian angles mentioned in the
bible.
While little is known about the tribe, we
met the only known survivor during the Wano
arc.
And as you can see they have a unique appearance,
with stunning white hair, enormous black wings,
and brown skin.
Plus you might have noticed he has literal
flames burning on his back.
Yup, that’s right.
They can control fire.
But what’s extra special about these flames
on his back is that when it is burning his
durability shoots way up so that even Zoro
cannot damage him at all.
However, for some reason when these flames
go out, he gets a speed boost, but his durability
drops so much that Zoro was able to defeat
him.
Beyond that, this Lunarian can also create
flaming blasts and even this fire dragon.
But that’s not even the most important thing
about the Lunarians because they used to be
considered a tribe of gods who lived on top
of the Red line.
Somehow though the tribe was nearly wiped
out, and I can pretty much guarantee that
it was because of the World Government who
tried to wipe them out after they took control
during the void century.
What’s even more SHOCKING though is the
INSANE idea that demons might actually exist
in One Piece.
Hear me out.
Have you ever wondered why devil fruits are
called what they are?
Well, wouldn’t it make sense if there was
once an actual devil or some other monster
that these fruits were named after?
And with recent reveals in the manga, we have
even more evidence that someone like the world
government’s secret ruler, Imu, and the
Gorosei might actually be immortal devils
who have lived ever since the void century.
Which would definitely explain how they’ve
been able to rule the world for so long.
But while this isn’t confirmed, another
secret race was just revealed in the manga
with the introduction of a group called the
Buccaneers, who in real life were pirates
that mostly sailed in the Caribbean.
Apparently, these people are a hybrid race
between humans and giants, which gives them
impressive size and strength, but in addition
to that they are one of the only known groups
of people who know about the history of the
legendary figure, Nika.
Of course, this is the name of Luffy’s devil
fruit, but it was also a historical person
from the distant past.
And the fact that the Buccaneers know about
Nika, and basically consider him a savior-type
figure, tells me that we will be learning
a lot more about this tribe and their connection
to Nika very soon.
And on top of this, one question I CANNOT
STOP thinking about is how strong was Nika?
Was he some legendary powerful figure who
freed the world with his strength?
And if so, will Luffy’s awakening make him
the most powerful Yonko in the entire world?
Well, if you want to know everything about
Luffy as an Emperor plus every single mouth-watering
secret about the other past and current Emperors,
you can watch that video right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.